- So you open up in the book
about like speaking of being
personal from the beginning.
That's what I loved about
how raw and real you are,
'cause I feel like sometimes
that's few and far between
with people in the public eye.
But you had to make an impossible decision
during a pregnancy.
And I have known people, that
have had the same scenario.
So what happened, you
know with the situation?
How did you cope with it?
'Cause that's a big
thing, to open up about.
- Well what's interesting is that
when we had to make a
decision because we found out,
once we got into the second
trimester right away.
Which usually, you know
once you get into that,
you're like "I'm in the clear."
- Yeah.
- But we found out
when we were into our second trimester
that there were some pretty
devastating health problems.
And that the baby was
at risk, I was at risk.
The baby probably wouldn't survive
and then I was at risk
for carrying any longer.
And we really weren't in a position to,
the writing was on the wall,
there was nothing we could do.
And my husband and I often say
that was the worst day of our lives.
Making that decision.
And--
Once I went through it,
I was really mad at my body and myself.
Like I thought I did
something to cause it.
Which I didn't.
I didn't.
- Yeah.
- You know but, you
just are trying so hard
to find an answer.
And I found that once I went through that,
I started finding out
about these other women
who have gone through similar losses.
And nobody was talking about it.
- Yeah.
- But I felt that it was
really important to write about it,
because I wanted other people
to be able to feel safe
to share their story.
And the fact that I wrote about it,
I can't tell you how many
people have reached out.
- I can't imagine.
- Explaining how much
it's helped them and now they're able
to vocalize what they went through,
or they feel seen and heard.
And, it's something that, was
really hard for me to share,
but I'm so glad I did
because it really helped
again build this community,
and made it safe for people to talk about.
- Yeah and I'm one who loves therapy.
So it just is sometimes
like learning and therapy--
Like just saying it out loud,
helps you heal.
- Right.
- Like just saying it out
loud and not keeping it inside
and it just kind of building up.
Like, saying it out loud
helps the person saying it.
Just as much as somebody
connecting to the message
and feeling the same way.
So it's very brave and it's very cool
and you're a very strong woman.